european union leaders have expressed
confidence that they have the right
strategy in place to rebuild their
economies as the EU gradually emerges
from the global downturn at their
two-day summit in brussels the leaders
emphasized the importance of restoring
financial stability to boost investor
confidence ensuring that public finances
are sound and the need for reform to
boost long-term growth and
competitiveness in view of our bleak
economic prospects in view of growing
social distress we looked very carefully
at the situation we are all fully
conscious of the debate the mounting
frustrations and even despair of people
we also know there are no easy answers
the only way out of the crisis is to
keep tackling its root causes around the
table there was a strong sense of
agreement about this the leaders
acknowledged that the fight against
unemployment and particularly youth
unemployment remains Europe's most
pressing social problem unemployment is
at an acceptable level that means we
must tackle the issue of fairness head
on the burden of many of our citizens in
particular in program countries is
becoming unbearable so they must feel
that the incredible efforts they are
making are for a reason they are spread
fairly and they are shared by all actors
in society including by the way by the
financial sector on international
affairs the leaders discuss Syria as the
humanitarian crisis there deepens some
nations want to lift the e use arms
embargo on the strife-torn country and
the leaders have tasked foreign
ministers to try to forge a common
stance on the way ahead at their
informal meeting in Dublin next week
ma positions de pasarme saldra Franz
cetacea sell yo yo Vinny c'est du Liban
abajo de la kulikov a mat no fat color
regime do basher al-assad hispidus am
allegedly it couldn't papa Orestes a
promotion regime do social the leaders
also discussed ways to strengthen the e
use partnership with Russia the union's
largest neighbor trading partner and
energy supplier busy in Austin identity
Gerson partner and meeting via phenom
fatigue ago to bits young and Valen via
xenon atoms of Aragon CIF on Sri kuttan
Venice on Fang dimension restaurant on
the skid via one Zionist haces para
decir latina lion at leisure position
they are mclean started on location when
you own a moon rock band host Lance
sahab leaders of the group of Nations
using the Euro single currency also held
talks on the sidelines of this European
Council